While loops in Swift aren't
particularly surprising.
They take the form, while, condition,
and then in between curly braces,
the statement that you want to execute.
Here's a while loop that's
counting down a timer.
While the timer's greater than zero,
Decker meant the timer.
In here you can see the loop
gets executed ten times.
Here's another while loop,
simulating having a beer with friends.
A beer with a lot of
toasting as it turns out, so
while beer volume is greater than zero,
cheers.
And then subtract the amount
you set from the volume,
and here you can see in the sidebar
that it's being executed 40 times.
Notice that here and
in the previous while loop,
there are no parentheses around the
conditions, just like with for loops.
Let's move on to repeat while loops.
Repeat while loops take the form repeat,
then the statements you want to execute
in between curly braces,
while a certain condition is true.
And as you can see, unlike while loops,
repeat while loops execute one time
before the condition is evaluated.
So I went ahead and commented out
the previous two while loops, and
you can see that we can write each
of those while loops as repeat while
loops like so.